you know what sketch you put in the book
that you said never got accepted and I
it sounds to me brilliant at least on
paper is a sketch of the family and the
mother says listen go to your room and I
don't want any monkey business and you
wrote a sketch where the guy goes in his
room and in there are like 20 monkeys
all with typewriters and computers and
you know all kinds of things and they're
actually conducting monkey business
there's monkey business going on the
bird why why would something like that
not get on the air tell Lorne is the
only way we try it a dress rehearsal and
then I actually thought it was funny and
I got cut and it was with Shia Shia
LaBeouf was the was the host and he
really liked it too we staged it and did
it and there was the moment of the
monkey business reveal and all that and
then at some point the monkeys he Shia
LaBeouf is like guys we gotta cut it out
no more monkey business and there's a
really dark turn and the monkeys stare
him down and they basically get together
and they agree to kill and they're like
we're gonna Ben we're gonna kill you
before you can end this business and it
turns into this deep like dark horror
movie at the end and a trailer thing
comes up it's like monkey business when
Lauren tells you no the monkey business
sketch is not gonna happen
can you go to this guy I mean I don't
understand this Lorne relationship like
can you go to him and say listen you're
[ __ ] wrong my man I was just a staff
writer and I had zero I mean even now
you know I would be first of all I don't
I don't really I want to go to the wall
for monkey business necessarily but the
most I would do is say like aa guy like
that or some you know I thought I can't
I'm just too shamed to ever say like
please put that off you know but I think
the way you do it which sometimes people
do is you resubmit it that's a way of
telling Lorne hey I actually do really
believe in this sketch and it's really
hard people submit like Will Forte used
to submit sketches he would submit like
the same sketch eight times until maybe
Lauren like cracked and let it go on and
sometimes it was one of the
sketches of the year
you